the most challenging part of running
this company it's not what you think
it's not raising money it's not you know
building it's honestly the most
challenging part is finding the right
people one one bad hire can send you a
completely different direction
sometimes for better sometimes For Worse
right but the most challenging thing is
definitely finding people who kind of
see the world the same way that you do
the most challenging part has probably
been leveling up myself in terms of my
EQ so I started the company when I was
18 and obviously hadn't lived much of
life and also didn't know how to deal
with people who are much older from
different backgrounds and with very
different communication Styles so I just
had to become a lot more empathetic I've
also had to think of personal health a
lot so in general I'm since I'm a
software person I hate thinking about
hardware and the body is Hardware so
even with limited hours in the day I
actually forced myself to take care of
myself my diet my sleep so that's been a
surprising challenge
[Music]
if you ask me today what the biggest
challenge is I would say I think being
able to maintain a strong and vibrant
culture in a company when it's growing
so fast we're now almost 500 employees
globally coming from a point where we
were you know 10 people 20 people and
going that fast in a short period of
time puts strains on structures of the
company culture how well you know you
walk together how you build Synergy with
different teams those things are
particularly hard when you grow that
fast
pandemic has has definitely posed a lot
of challenges I think one of the biggest
ones that everyone is facing is how do
you
create a really productive work culture
and team some people do hybrid you know
we kind of dabbled with hybrid and
remote and it's tough because you want
to find the best people wherever they
are but you when you're creating a
startup especially not just an
established company you really need
people eating lunch together going to
the water cooler together having those
late night whiteboarding sessions so
we've definitely tried to create as much
of that as we can but it never feels
like enough
[Music]
there I have many challenges on the way
but I would just say to every like
everybody going and like doubting
themselves and not being sure just like
find like a fundamental set of values
that you would apply and stick to them
and and believe in yourself it doesn't
always make sense and I think for me was
definitely like moving frequently for my
career to in order to be able to achieve
my career aspiration right like a
Biotech Industry Venture Capital doesn't
exist where I come from so I had to like
make some of these hard decisions very
early but I was necessary for me to be
able to become who I am and to have the
opportunity to to run this company and
everything I ever achieved until then
and in terms of the company I would say
that I mean I have to say everywhere
where I live the United States is a
place where I felt most valued I'm so
lucky to to call it home however even
here in today's day and age I believe
that often saying that you have a
biotechnology company working in women's
health people were like really like why
because we see a lot of consumerism a
lot of digital Health but we don't
really have a lot of investments in
biotechnology and pharmaceutical
research for women women were not part
of even clinical trials until a couple
of decades ago so I feel like showing
that you can build a reputable business
there that is in women's health that is
trying to be a biotech company is a
challenge that I hope will will prove
because there are not too many companies
working in this space and I would love
them to be more
when it comes to being a business leader
there's a lot of decisions that you have
to make that others may find weird or
different when you're thinking about the
community that you're serving and the
mission that you're trying to do for us
at all Trail we started by calling each
one of our members the onboard the
Montour app and when we called them it
wasn't just to get onto the app try it
out it was who are you where are you
from what church do you go to really
connecting with our members on a one by
one basis to understand why they were
coming to ultra and what we could aim to
do for them and by talking to our
members we learned that very quickly
work even consumer Tech especially
Finance is very tricky and the main word
is regulations compliance and all the
howls in the space on actually
delivering a product when you think
about
Banks or fintechs or people that are
trying to change the game in the finance
world you realize there's a million
steps to take one step that you would
take in outside of the finance space so
although we're doing a public good for
our members the regulations the
compliance and all the bureaucracy in
the space makes it very difficult it
makes it capital intensive and just
makes it hard to move one step forward
day by day
the most challenging part of running the
company so far is it stretched me in
ways I couldn't have imagined I've had
to learn a lot and I've had to learn it
very quickly and sometimes while I'm
doing it stop putting the airplane
together while you're trying to fly it
aspect and I think that it's been an
incredible experience for me just
because I've gotten to flex muscles I
didn't know I had and I've gotten to
essentially build up an organization
from the ground which I I never thought
I would have the opportunity to do
[Music]